Speaker 1: Another player is entering the 2024
Republican primary. It's former Arkansas Governor
Asa Hutchinson who will be running against
Donald Trump, Nikki Haley and Vivek Ramaswamy.
He announced this when speaking to Jonathan Karl
from ABC. Not exactly making huge headlines,
understandably, but let's take a listen.
Speaker 5: When I spoke to you earlier this year,
you said you were thinking about running for
president. Have you made a decision? Are you
running? I have made a decision. And my decision
is I'm going to run for president of the United
States. Wow. The formal announcement will be
later in April in Bentonville. I wanted to
make that'll be a real party player. That to
you, Jonathan. I am going to be running. And
the reason is I've traveled the country for six
months. I hear people talk about the leadership
of our country. And I'm convinced that people
want leaders that appeal to the best of America
and not simply appeal to our worst instincts.
Speaker 1: I always find it funny when they say
they've traveled the country, and I know it's sort
of like you have to do it and you have to say it,
but do you really need to travel the
country to figure out a lot of these
things? It's always a weird thing to hear.
Speaker 5: And that inspires me when I see
everyday Americans. You're saying give us good
leadership, give us common sense, consistent
conservatism and optimism about our great country.
And that inspires me. And I believe I can be
that kind of leader for the people of America.
Speaker 1: All right. So he has absolutely no
shot, but it is interesting to see more people
enter. If I were a betting man and I'm not,
my guess is Asa Hutchinson doesn't even make
it past the first Republican primary. Now,
that being said, more candidates generally
does seem to be better for Donald Trump. The
more people there are running the Republican
primary, what we see in the polling is that
it helps Trump versus DeSantis. We have some
new ish polls. I'm trying to look at ones that
are actually sort of like, well, well rated.
There's a Trafalgar Group poll, which is a
right leaning poll. It's a Multi-way poll. It
has Trump over DeSantis by 34 with Liz Cheney,
who doesn't seem to have any plan to run at 10%.
Then we have an insider advantage poll that's a
B rated poll. Trump over DeSantis by 33. And then
we have a B-plus rated YouGov poll. In this poll,
Trump does better with more candidates. This
isn't surprising. This is what we've seen when
it is just Trump versus DeSantis. Trump leads
by 26 and when it is Trump versus a whole bunch
of. People. Trump leads by 31, and we could
go further, but this is sort of where we are
right now. So interesting that Asa Hutchinson is
running. I truly wonder when people like this run.
Are they sitting in a room where someone is
telling them you've got a shot at winning?
Because they obviously don't? Or is it that
they're sitting in a room and advisers say
you don't have a shot, but this might raise your
public profile, You might get yourself on a debate
stage, and then you can parlay that into being a
contributor to Fox News or something like what is
actually in their minds when they decide to run.
What do they think versus what is the reality of
what can come from it and what is the basis on
which they're making these these decisions. It's
an interesting thing. We now have a four way race
in the Republican primary with one of those four
candidates under indictment. And we're going to
very closely follow the direction that this goes